sir Graham Brady has confirmed that he
has received 48 letters from
conservative MPs so there will now be a
vote of confidence in my leadership of
the Conservative Party
I will contest that vote with everything
I've got I have been a member of the
Conservative Party for over 40 years
I've served it as an activist
councillor MP Shadow Minister Home
Secretary and now as Prime Minister I
stood to be leader because I believe in
the conservative vision for a better
future a thriving economy with nowhere
and nobody left behind a stronger
society where everyone can make the most
of their talents all we're serving the
national interest and at this crucial
moment in our history that means
securing a brexit deal that delivers on
the result of the EU referendum taking
back control of our borders laws and
money but protecting jobs our security
and our precious union as we do so
through good times and bad over the last
two years my passionate belief that such
a deal is attainable that a bright
future lies ahead for our country has
not wavered and it is now within our
grasp